Apollo 11 Mission Commander Neil Armstrong will forever be remembered for setting foot on the moon...
...and uttering these immortal words:...
..."That's one small step for man,...
...one giant leap for mankind."
Now he says, the space race between the United States and the former Soviet Union...
...that culminated with the Apollo missions served a valuable purpose.
It was the ultimate...
...peaceful competition.
USA versus USSR.
It was intense. It did allow both sides to take the high road,...
...with the objectives of science and learning and exploration.
Eventually, it provided a mechanism...
...for engendering cooperation...
...between former adversaries.
In that sense, among others, it was an exceptional national investment for both sides.
Images of Armstrong and Lunar Module Pilot Edwin Buzz Aldrin on the moon...
...were seen by more than half a billion enraptured viewers on Earth.
To this day, the Apollo 11 Mission remains one of humanity's greatest...
...and most celebrated technological achievements.